olá pessoal de quem fala dar que sejam
muito bem vindos
é mais um menino e eu mostrar de que um
brinquedo novo que eu encontrei numa
loja e foi só aí que desde criança
sempre quis ter este brinquedo
basicamente que são ovos de dinossauro
que eu posso colocar dentro d'água e
passado algum tempo os ovos que eclodem
e financiamento em dinossauros olha isso
é muito louco sério já só tem que tirar
ex avaí eo verbo brincar com a edição
para o solo em ficaram direx a lei
ontem o ex vai perceber que por isso foi
só de mulheres e para nós percebemos
como é que isso funciona vamos ler as
instruções ali está muito fácil é só
colocar um ovo dentro d'água eu passar
algum tempo 12 e 12 e 24 horas para 24
horas o que circula silvy ter visto
instante
inclusive isso é que é feito com um
material que provisoriamente fica assim
muito grande então vai ficar muito
grande mesmo eu não estava esperando pra
24 horas portanto eu vou ter que começar
o vídeo amanhã mas já disputaram de que
nossa experiência é porque exprime a
minha experiência eu quero muito vai que
neste vídeo pessoal é especial por eles
vão começar a me escalar os novos focos
está ou com um gorro
porém o chão é muito ruim né é é meu
isso que é igualzinho novo dinossauro
olha aí eu nunca vi uma vida não só nós
teimamos em dois blocos aqui em baixo ok
um ovo dois ovos
a e3 ovos em software de compressão e
comprei logo quatro ovos porto pode ser
que na sua obra enfrentadas de vários
tipos de dinossauro é isso que nós
milhões e aparentemente eu são todos
iguais não há diferença não é de crise
nenhuma e agora nós com isso conseguimos
dois resultados o senhor edson todos
iguais ou então vai ser diferente espera
sair de frente mas cometem embaixo que
você já acha um passeio em frente acham
que vão ser igual como ei o que eu
preciso de vocês dá agora precisava de
um recipiente para colocar água
espera aí olha aqui já procurei o vídeo
claro
instruções e colocar o nosso povo e eu
não testei o carro e acho que a produção
não 10 da argentina
vamos lá estar 321 o o ou quase nenhum
centavo para o chão olha aí mas entrou e
agora é só colocar um saco aqui dentro
então já fez amor
bora lá só tem aqui um recipiente com
água outro recipiente com água foto 2
ela quer e eles é que os outros dois
recipientes foi muito complicado em
jerez porque isso ricken 12 mil de uma
casa em taxa de água mas para lá pessoal
agora é muito fácil é só colocar o nosso
hora e 32 13 jun efe o lucro a entrar
água dentro do ovo para comer gostar de
xira
olha só fica vivo embora lá colocar os
restantes ovos
olha só oi isso é muito lucro estão não
têm que respirar ea água e mesmo dentro
mas mesmo assim acho que eu tenho que
colocar mais água porque agora o tio o
caí
o outro ouro aqui eu gosto muito disto a
lesão
a gota de cheiro de um jogo para o nosso
quarto uvo que tem muita água
meu deus pessoal é assim que funciona
aqui na colômbia
olha só queria limpar ou acho que eu sou
a primeira pessoa que encarna a limpar
uma mesa como como esse problema mas com
isso eu tive uma grande ideia porque
aqui dentro precisa de mais água mas não
vou buscar algo normal né eu vou usar a
posição do fornalha aí está não só esta
opção do fornatur que dá muita energia
escudo isso não se tem não só os bem
esta opção vão mexer com mais curto
então é isso que vamos fazer lá eu vou
destinar esta opção uso por 31 vai
olha é isso acho que uns chegar à cura
assunção
tal idéia eu acho que falei meu deus
agora sim vou mexer terek muito forte e
eu ainda vou tentar outra coisa calma
calma calma vou testar se estava
prevista no tac que a 2003
nem sei que está muito suja eu vou
testar três não vai estar muito bom está
lá continuar só vão juntar aqui os
nossos jovens que dizer não vou
continuar nada porque agora é só esperar
a única coisa que eu posso fazer só vou
lançar aqui um desafio se vocês acham
que vai funcionar vou mexer em que
dinossauros cometem em baixo este
dinossauro e fazer já choveu mais cheio
de que nada de provar isso é uma coisa
bem estranha cometer em baixo e segue a
linha pode ser que nasce uma galinha
mesmo que não saibam se elas iam embora
lá pessoal depois de 48 horas que os
praia os jogos eclodiram olha aí olha só
neste ano os dinossauros a cabeça de
fora estão triceratops muito louca e tal
como eu disse agora nesta quarta trio e
esperar 24 horas que ia colocar a câmera
fazer painel apps mexe eo 'mal a caixa
supostamente a primeira fazer entre 12 a
24 horas ea segunda fase a inclusão
neste essa sim em 48 horas nenhum
encaixam então eu fiquei desiludido por
ter que esperar mais um dia
por isso aos que acessam a web foi
superfaturado e unhas prática a câmara
tinha gravado 48 horas com os irmãos mas
é que temos só os novos dinossauros
invasão só isso aqui é bem gordo e tem
uma música morto
este é o terceiro a top se eu acho olha
aí é bem gordo também esquenta para um
sapo sei lá eu igual a essa
isso aqui não sei se é igual a isso
mesmo parece nem o é diferente
eu acho que há diferentes formas com as
quais quatro de nossos olhos de frente
muita sorte vamos pensar qual é o tema
que vamos colocar 500 lado meus parecem
ser muito grande
ele foi como podem ver abril mesmo a
casca luís i
é muito estranho ok pessoal vamos
alavancar o nosso dinossauro e en 321 am
lembrou está muito gordo e lançou viu
muita água
olha isso pelo que isto não parece não
sabida é isso aí só como embaixo quando
é que vai ser o nosso favorito este é o
nosso número nunca e vamos lá próximo um
novo estoque mas tudo de nós o número 2
onde esteve e está muito gordo também a
estender seus três filhos por cima
olha isso este aqui parece um dinossauro
este sim acho que é um chamariz do sul
faz uma senão não estava dentro do ovo
com água limitada imagina se o cara está
aqui dentro de um balde e uma caixa com
muita água e eu ia ficar muito grande da
china deixando a iata estima pessoal é
isso mesmo eu vou colocar estes
dinossauros na china como dante disso
muito boa ideia é nada não é daqueles
tempos vão mostrar como é que ficaram
talvez vamos trabalhar no instagram
portanto parcelado em forma ou eu vou
deixar aqui de novo o número dois de
lado vamos bailar próximo dinossauro
vamos lá herrán em rock é expressivo
muito igual onde não só o número mas
vamos ver 31 vai arrancar em lauro leis
oeste é muito bonito igual só que também
maior que chutou muito mais nada daqui
se for muito mais vagas ele fez não só
como um salto olha isso
afinal eles não soubessem salvar a opel
só comecei que não tem muito rocha que
em si mesmo que tem muito roxo como é
que uma mutação genética qualquer eu
acho que isso é que houve uma expulsão
do formigão sair mas jamais por frei tem
mais coisa que o sinteam está 100 certo
para lá virá só no morumbi não só no
mundo hoje nosso número 3 vamos ver o
quarto nos ao este caso como favorito
porque é muito grande pra lá 321 mil
está muito apertado dentro da embalagem
feita por lei
parece um cão
é isso eu adoro isto não pode ver
ninguém olha olha aqui é flamengo e fred
isso mesmo em férias ontem patrús muito
grande estava engordando em garrafa é e
arranhões por 18 anos e eu asseguro que
os nossos calçados pessoal é o nosso
triceratops olha aí é graham e agora só
vamos tentar quebrar um dinossauro numa
e eu vou usar o irmão mais pequeno só
para fazer o texto e este aqui vou
colocar na piscina e ver se no esquenta
fica melhor porque agora é só ficar em 3
não vai não tá muito tempo ou não da
sério é muito resistente e bora lá
bandido que o material é feito nós quem
não sabe o duro que eu queria uma mãe o
que é isso aqui é um material do níger
bem mais denso sabe até mais ver mais
complexa agora vou contar dinossauro
maior a321 aproxima e procel a a a
condenação da mulher ai meu deus olha o
casino e dentro une a aqui por dentro
estava em seca então ela é capaz de
expandir ainda mais que eu acho que a
piscina vai ajudar agora ela só atende
quem eu sou de push mail para lançar uma
pergunta o que você já se acham que este
dinossauro bóia ou vai afundando
petróleo está muito pesado
há muitos anos eu só comentei que vocês
acham
só que agora em 32 o total para o balcão
como eu
só pode ser assim daqui que eu faço vai
levantando em juízo um pano dentro um
prédio do teste um carro com milhares de
pessoas aqui dentro que é melhor para o
tablet ou seja saem são distribuídos a
abrir os colecionáveis de abrir coisas
deste género comida embaixo porque eu
posso fazer mais mas só se você está bem
também porque não deixei muito aqui no
canal isso não foram inscritos quench
carregam quiserem ver mais de nós aqui
no canal cometem este dinossauro não é
normal é de nos salvar ou como é que eu
vou fazer esse toque na china então é a
mesma coisa que o dinossauro
só que dinossauro do rock como é que eu
vou fazer o gol é o nosso grupo mas é só
tem um staff que vai até aproximar